and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review in such spoilers
fiercest movie called inception and
stars Jack from Titanic Tommy from third
Rock Juno and all the side characters in
Batman Begins so here's these people who
want to find out information about these
other people and they do it by going
through their dreams I didn't had
someone go through my dreams once except
he was an evil man with claws in a
fedora hat I think his name with Dick
Cheney and this one ancient guy what's
the dream happens to go to the sauna
person's dream and the ancient guy is
like to Moscow for the tosin Abasi de
Winter Park he's kind of hard to
understand kind of like they're tied
from the room yeah we're gonna review of
that go anyway but the camera know is
like I don't want to work for you you
have nothing to offer me
and yes your guys like I can make it so
that you are not wanted for murder you
can see your kids again really how can
you do that I am powerful fictional
business guy I can make anything happen
I'm not Donald Trump except my hair
isn't alive even architect to build the
team the DiCaprio's father this person's
mind it's an idea that he's gonna think
what's his crazy three levels of
dreaming confused hit where don't be and
if you go past the third level dreaming
you'll end up in tempo oh hello
existential can you collect essential
can you kill but there's this evil woman
who's actors got that it turns out mr.
Jeffrey's body and I'm like I know the
twist of this movie's gonna be it's
gonna be the she's dead the whole time
yeah they did that in the first 20
minutes
Oh what about the twist is that's gonna
be a dream within a dream map they did
then the first five minutes of the movie
we yeah in fact it's a to your dream
within the dream within a dream within
between oh well um I present twisted
than Tommy you today the end well that's
right then the twist is that there may
or may not be a twist at the end
what this seriously awesome
I'm so
that's so perfect this movie rocks
really cool action sequences what I'm
flying all over the place it's like the
matrix except unpretentiously smarts and
all the characters are going around
doing cool things and DiCaprio is like
you are departing is like is like
DiCaprio gets everybody else alive he
finally gets to go home to see his
children and the army of happily ever
after
or do it actually we don't know we don't
know this movie raises so many boggling
questions like how do I know I'm not
dreaming right now
duh well how do I know I'm not dreaming
right now
how okay I'm going to take some drugs to
support from this movie oh this is
jittery boom c-come on just imagine is a
dream you need money in a dream